Bohemian Rhapsody won the Oscar for Best
editing at the 2019 Academy Awards this
is interesting because the movie
contains several scenes that are master
classes and poor editing right now that
everybody's got an acceptable name let's
get to it look we just really need
something special more hits like Killer
Queen let's examine one of the worst
offenders in the film and breakdown why
exactly the editing of the scene is so
bad the cuts in this scene are
particularly jarring they stand out to
an attentive audience member for three
reasons first many of the cuts are
unmotivated second many ignore spatial
continuity and third the pace is simply
too fast let's deal with the easiest of
these problems first if a cut is
unmotivated another reason you might
choose to cut is to create or maintain
the pace of a scene or to build tension
you can see this kind of effect during
this scene from The Godfather where
editor Walter Murch in a moment of
silence chooses to cut back and forth
between these two characters it's almost
like the audience is anxiously looking
back and forth between them waiting to
see who will speak using pacing to
create tension or emotion however can't
just be forced upon a scene through the
Edit you have to work with and
complement the performances and
cinematography and in fact the faster
the pace the more attention must be paid
to things like spatial continuity errors
will simply lead to more difficulty
following the action the pace of this
scene is incredible in this 104 second
scene there are an astounding 60 cuts
for an average shot length of 1.8
seconds to put this into perspective
this 136 second fight scene from
Transformers the last night only has 49
cuts and an average shot length of 2.8
seconds
that's an action sequence from one of
the most notoriously hyperactive
directors out there compare that to the
scene of some guys sitting around a
table that's over 30% faster absolutely
nothing about this scene justifies or
requires this kind of ridiculous pace
the rest of the film is fast paced and
the pace fits a little bit better for
the musical and concert sequences I can
see how they were possibly trying to
keep the energy level high for the
dialogue scenes as well but it just
doesn't work the pacing is the most
obvious issue but it's far from the only
one let's examine some of these cuts in
detail and the other two things that
make the edits so jarring the primary
thing that motivates most cuts is the
revelation of new information most
important is emotional information a
large majority of the cuts in a dialogue
driven scene are so we can see a
character's face as they deliver a line
or are reacting to somebody else's line
new information can also be geographic
to establish the character's
relationship to each other spatially or
to let the audience see an action that's
taking place of course a shot can
contain multiple pieces of new
information but it's rarely a good idea
to make a cut when that shot reveals no
new information at all let's examine
what motivates some of the cuts in this
scene they know is fancy-dress right
I've got to make an impression darling
you look like an angry lizard the scene
starts off decently we get a nice shot
that starts with Freddie Mercury coming
through the doors and pans into a wide
the second shot gives us a better view
of Freddie approaching the table and the
third allows us to see the delivery of
the first line by Brian May
I know his fancy dress right then we cut
back to the shot of Freddie to see him
showing off the outfit and then to a
close-up of his emotional reaction to
Brian's line we probably could have
stayed on the line here but jumping into
the close-up isn't a huge issue then we
cut to Roger Taylor's reaction to Brian
second line and then back to Brian's
reaction to Rogers laugh we cut back to
Freddy to see his laugh and the action
of him sitting down as well as John Reed
entering in the background so far okay
this is an oscar-worthy editing but the
cuts reveal new information and makes
sense it's a little bit too fast but
it's establishing the nervous energy of
the band as they wait for the meeting to
begin but this is where the scene begins
to run into some major trouble let's
watch very successful way so here we cut
to Brian's line but then we cut back
very quickly to see the rest of Freddy
sitting down and then quickly back to
Brian again we already know Brian is
making these wisecracks so seeing him
deliver the line isn't super important
we already know Freddy is sitting down
so returning to the shot of him sitting
down is repetitive information and his
reaction is still the same as before
either of these shots would likely be
fine to hold on but the quick
back-and-forth creates the first sense
of whiplash that will only worsen as
this scene progresses on the shot of
Brian we see John Reed pass by John
grabbing the chair interrupts the band's
casual chat following that shot we have
two reaction shots back-to-back one from
Brian and one from Freddy where they're
both looking up towards where John
Reed's face would be however since two
shots have passed since we last saw John
standing in that position the eyeline of
these reactions is a little bit awkward
also both of these reactions would be
happening simultaneously
it looks like the editor tries to make
it feel more simultaneous by cutting
quickly but it doesn't sell now we get a
shot of Reed that establishes the
correct eyeline height but his eyeline
looks like it is directed at John Deacon
and Roger Taylor but instead of cutting
to them we cut back to Brian for a
second reaction shot we can even fix
this fairly easily just by swapping
these two shots
still not great but it's a little bit
better after John Reid sits down the
eyeline is again completely ignored
while we've just cut from John and Roger
it now looks like he's looking at
Freddie
then Reid shifts his eye line over to
where John and Roger are sitting and we
cut to Freddie
this section flows much better if we
just remove some of the complexity
here's the original edit so this is
great and here's my simplified cut so
this is Quaid
again it's not perfect but if I can
smooth things out just by shifting the
existing shots around there's no reason
an editor with access to all the footage
couldn't have cut a better scene let's
look at the next section so this is
Queen and you must be Freddie Mercury
you've got a gift you all have so tell
me what makes Queen any different from
all of the other wanna be rock stars I
meet after this line so this is Quaid we
immediately run into another problem
Reed says so this is Quaid and we cut to
a shot of exactly 3/4 of Queen it would
make way more sense to show all four of
them here there's not anything that
these three are doing that explains
specifically cutting to just the three
of them we cut quickly back to Reed but
he's completely shifted in his seat the
character making this kind of movement
off camera is usually fine but less than
a second passes between these cuts so it
almost appears as a jump cut also this
spatial orientation of where he's
pointing is confusing coming off of this
poorly chosen wide shot it would make a
ton of sense to break up the pacing here
with a longer shot of Freddie but
instead of holding on Freddie for a
longer reaction we cut back to a
completely strange new angle of Reed
this new angle gives us nothing by the
way of new emotion
or spatial information and it just
continues to add complexity to a scene
that's already going by too quickly then
we go back to this awkward wide that
includes only three of the band members
presumably because there's no wide of
all four band members to show all their
reactions the editor has to patch
together an awkward combination of this
wide and this close-up which just
doesn't gel at all the lack of a good
wide including all four members of the
band I think is a core difficulty with
this scene and it might be a clue that
part of the blame here falls on the
director or cinematographer for not
getting proper coverage or just blocking
and composing the scene poorly we
continue to get reaction shots that are
unnecessary we've already seen this
expression on these band members faces
in shots 22 and 24 we don't need to see
it again and this would have been a
great chance to slow things down I could
continue to work through each cut in
this scene but many of the cuts have
these same repeated issues one key
offender sticks out here we cut to a
wide shot where Paul magically appears
beside John Reed not to mention this
jump to a super wide shot is completely
unmotivated and doesn't make any sense
it's usually difficult to judge who's at
fault when it comes to editing if an
editor is given a scene that's poorly
blocked and composed it's difficult to
fix that in the Edit however it seems
unlikely that cutting this scene in this
way and choosing this pace was the best
option the editor had with the scene
this is easily the worst edited scene in
the film but many of the dialogue scenes
have the same issues this scene has
there are plenty of scenes with
perfectly functional editing although
I'd be hard-pressed to find examples of
the kind of editing you'd hope would
earn an Academy Award
there's also examples of awkward
transitions or montages that cover
periods of touring but do a poor job of
conveying the necessary feeling so why
did this film win an Academy Award for
Best editing just like I mentioned
editing is hard to judge good editing
should rarely be noticeable good editing
tells the story effective
and when a movie is edited well you
usually walk away from it thinking that
was a great film not that editing was
good
so counter-intuitively the Oscar
sometimes ends up going to films with
the most noticeable editing which
generally is not the film with the best
editing there was a lot of turmoil
during the production of this film so I
can understand how this film maybe ended
up how it did it's easier to pick apart
bad editing than it is to edit a scene
that's not shot well but an Academy
Award for Best editing for this film is
completely undeserved an editing like
this ultimately is disrespectful to the
audience it assumes your attention span
is so short that your attention has to
be held with quick flashy cuts sometimes
an editor just needs to step back slow
down and trust that an audience member
who's chosen to come see your film is
interested and invested in the story
thanks to audible for sponsoring this
video sign up for a 30-day free trial
today and get a free audiobook when you
go to audible.com slash Thomas flight or
text thomas flight to 500 500 you'll get
an audiobook and two audible originals
each month so I have some suggestions
for you if you're interested in learning
more about Queen and Freddie Mercury and
don't want to subject yourself to
hyperactive editing you can check out
mercury and me by Jim Hutton one of my
favorite books about business is
anything you want by Derek Siver's I've
listened to it again every couple of
years since I first listened to it in
2011 I used the audio book as a way to
help keep my priorities and focus on
track give audible a try today and maybe
you'll find that audiobooks that you
keep revisiting for the rest of your
life just go to audible.com slash Thomas
Flight click on the link in the
description or text thomas flight to 500
500 to try audible free for 30 days
thanks so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video and want to see more
of this type of content hit that
subscribe button and go to
patreon.com/scishow this flight where
you can learn more about how you can
support my channel and get extra cool
stuff while you do special thank-you to
my patrons